and I do that with a sort of a half-hour
bump to fall asleep to maybe read for a
minute whatever but I'm in bed usually
by 10:00 I've never gone to a
psychiatrist but one one of the shows
that I was on I was like the only person
on the set that didn't go to a
psychiatrist I'm like maybe I'm [ __ ]
up no by the way if you're functioning
in the world that's great
congratulations I have sometimes trouble
functioning in the world how sad and end
day well it's like I find going on stage
I'm fearless and I don't even like
leaving my house I prefer to stay home I
love napping if I could smoke some
indica and take a nap every day I do
Transcendental Meditation I do all the
chill things at home and I leave to work
I don't like going to parties I like a
good dinner party because that means I
can have an actual conversation with
someone right but I would just had a
party the other night a goodbye party
for a friend of mine it was at Jeff
Ross's house and I had the worst time I
lasted 20 minutes then when people I
could talk to her comedians yeah there
would be at Jeff Ross's party but
comedian well some people with man buns
in a hot tub it was very unsettling I
wanted nothing to do but I said my
goodbyes to my friend and she's moving
to Japan so I I said my goodbyes but I
was out of respect to her that I went
but out of respect to myself I didn't
stay long man buns in a hot tub yeah you
don't belong there yeah
I can't be done no it's bad when did
that start happening when the man bun it
talks to me like in a big way a couple
years ago
just like samurais and then there was a
big drop off for a long time that's
exactly I don't get it mommy why grow
your hair long if you're gonna wear a
man bun I think either way you're lying
and yeah the idea it's ridiculous I was
at a gas station in Studio City and I
was seconds away from talking to this
dude he had a man bond that looked like
a bird's nest with faithlyn with a
waterfall on the outside and I just went
why I'd be totally friendly I want to
make this a conversation why explain I
don't get it I feel like what it is is
just like they're they're letting you
know that this is me when I'm out but
when I'm at home and I'm feeling sexy I
just undo that and let it down I don't
know what it is I just relax and I
unwrap a big bowl along it's a big
bowling and no you're not dear douchey
sex you're douchey what's this your
hairs ever been mine
I had like a jew-fro type festival
happening when I was younger like longer
curlier but not in like shoulder length
right no it's ridiculous it's weird that
hair grows that long only on your head
that's weird
and you're grown like Robert Plant's
head cool hair like go for it
don't man bonnet yeah go for it I'm all
for long hair rockers have different
rules I saw a guy last night a band a
band bass player big man bun big bowling
wrong you know what I'm uncomfortable
with a CEO haircut in a rock band Oh
what are you doing with that [ __ ]
button-down conservative hair I dig the
band I think playing against type is a
big bowl of delightful nah not in this
one we differ on this group of men like
I thought David Bowie's ban Tin Machine
I didn't really dig their music but I
loved the look of all them wearing the
suits with the close cropped hair well
Bowie's so odd and so undeniably
creative that he was allowed to get away
with anything he's a lot do anything you
want but but truthfully if you have any
sort of confidence you can accept a man
bun there it is right here history of
yeah Bowie's yeah but that dude should
have cut his hair short that won't the
long here maybe but he's kind of John
Travolta in Polish he cut it short here
he is the pressure from the other three
guys
got to be too much that's hired of
buying shampoo and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah the upkeep is ridiculous
it's outrageous yeah dudes who
conditioned their hair and they have to
leave it in for ten minutes that's a big
bowl of come on man come on bro yeah but
for something there's some reason why it
is okay in a band but it's not okay for
a comic like a comic with long like Led
Zeppelin hair because you know what
happens when a comic does that their
whole act becomes about it and it's like
dude hmm that's just boring
remember Jackson Perdue i do remember
jackson pretty crazy long hair yeah like
a band yeah guy yeah a lot of material
about his hair I know I just you know I
used it when I was younger I went for
the obvious I did a lot of material
about having a big head no now did some
no interest to me
no you couldn't also do like the Robert
Plant shirt thing I have I have a Robert
Plant shirt not ever like opener I think
it's cause that nurses do it better or
nurses and someone nursing out it's
powder blue he warned I'm one of the
Zeppelin tours in the 70s and I saw it
for sale on Amazon and I bought one it
doesn't give off the same time yeah it's
different with different people right